I've seen people who have a lot of
potential or great potential who don't
necessarily have the discipline or like
hit that point of like Pro like I'm
gonna do this whether you know no matter
what
what are your thoughts on natural Talent
are people born talented
um
I think so I think everyone's born with
uh a little some something and then like
I feel like the people who really hone
it those are kind of they go on to
become really great at what they do for
sure so I think natural Talent is
important it'll give you a leg up but
there are also people out there who just
are such hard workers that just have
crazy persistence I have many filmmaker
friends like this who are like come from
kind of like the Navy Sea seal world and
uh and we'll still uh somehow kind of I
guess just beat that craft to death to
where they catch up I think with the
natural talent in my opinion
when did you know you had town foreign
I don't know if I do I I hope so but
um
I don't know I think like I started
making videos when I was like 11 years
old on YouTube and uh it's because I
didn't like school and that was the only
thing that was kind of around me like a
little Windows Movie Maker editing
system I'm like a horrible Dell but uh
my mom uh is a very funny person and if
I could ever get her to laugh or uh pay
attention to me that would be a success
so I think I found through those YouTube
videos that was a way of of uh getting
getting that kind of response and I
think once she started showing her
friends and they all thought you know
these little goofy videos I was making
were interesting or funny that's kind of
when I knew I was like oh maybe I should
keep doing this I like this
and you grew up between is it the
Pacific Northwest and Peru yeah yeah I
grew up between Seattle and Peru and
South America so was the grunge movement
already had already passed at that point
or was it still
how come not a musician how did you know
you had talent I guess to uh for acting
and filmmaking how come you didn't want
to be the next um Eddie Vedder Lane
Staley I secretly do okay I secretly do
want to be I mean a rock star uh uh no
that's an interesting question I've
never been asked that
um
hmm I went to school with like a lot of
musicians and and when I was really
young I also loved to paint and I was a
graffiti artist for a little bit uh my
mom didn't like that one but
um she's so supportive she she got
someone to teach me how to get better at
it you know you know so uh I think when
I when I exhausted all my punk uh grunge
routes you know I was like dang it
nothing is pissing off my parents
they're just supportive I finally like
kind of found my own uh my own music and
I think like in editing for example
writing it's very musical to me
um or even directing which I do a little
bit of uh oftentimes I'll find myself
communicating like
like that you know do it like you know
like musically and half the time people
be like what are you talking about and
the other half uh who are more musically
inclined I think really get it and
that's like a good way of communicating
so
um there it was a lot of punk kind of uh
happening in Seattle when I was living
there for sure but I was a little bit on
the outskirts of it or finding my own
Punk if that makes sense
well to skateboarding I'm sure worried
them right yes yes
that was a little bit of my street crowd
being a skateboarder
what does it mean to work so hard that
you're eventually sick of it
um
I'm not there yet I haven't worked so
hard that I've gotten sick of it just
yet but uh I mean
I think he's just being being a
professional when you work so hard and
you feel sick of it but you keep going
that's I think when you can really
decide oh I'm a pro at this like I will
show up regardless of how I feel or what
people say I'm gonna do this
what comes to mind when you hear the
word potential
the word potential kind of like scares
me
um not in dating but in but in in acting
potential in dating is not so great but
potential in career may be different
yeah
um yeah the word potential used to be so
much more exciting than it is to me now
like when I started and I heard
potential it was like that's awesome
like uh it to me potential meant like a
quick come up in a weird way like you
have potential you can make a great jump
very quickly
um
but I guess living in LA and being in
the business for a little bit now I mean
much less Long than most people but
still a minute
um I've seen a lot of people come in and
come out of this system and being
discouraged and the word potential to me
to be honest kind of like
touches my heart in a weird way where
I've seen people who have a lot of
potential or great potential who don't
necessarily have the discipline or like
hit that point of like Pro like I'm
gonna do this whether you know no matter
what
um that kind of burnout you know
um and it's kind of sad because there's
a lot of talented friends I've had
who've gone in and gone out of I guess
Hollywood or their dreams even you know
um so potential scary that's what it is
to me you know I hope I hope I've passed
the potential space in my mind and have
gotten to the you know everyday grind
and how did you know that you would
stick with it I mean two if we want to
go back to and I'm sorry to keep using
the Seattle grunge scene but that's
something that I always wish I had been
a part of
um there were people that unfortunately
didn't make it you know and died
probably way too young and were
extremely talented so how did you know
did did you see that around you growing
up or hear about it yeah definitely
definitely and I was getting deep yeah I
uh maybe that's why yeah when I hear
potential I do think of a lot of the
people I grew up with who were insane
musicians were just really great artists
whether they had their singular Focus
you know their rapper graffiti artist
skater like all these things in one uh
who've passed away you know who have
overdosed on like fentanyl or something
crazy and that's the crazy thing about I
think art and artists A lot of the time
is that I think
I think a lot of people get stuck in the
idea that like drugs or or alcohol or
like living a Crazy Life uh can fuel
your art and I've been through parts of
that myself but uh I think ultimately if
you don't if you don't sit down and use
that kind of those experiences or really
like hone in and be like okay let me put
that back in the Shelf uh and either
come back to it or never come back to it
again then you can't really do anything
with it and and I've seen a lot of
friends uh of mine and uh and even
people I don't know go through that
where they get caught in that a little
bit they see a little success or a
little inspiration on on the wild
lifestyle and and unfortunately don't
get to do anything with it you know I
remember somebody in La telling me that
so many people in Hollywood who
delete to them they don't want it as
much and it really had me thinking about
some of the people that I knew was that
true because maybe it was so easy for
them whether people were just you know
drawn to them naturally and they didn't
really have to work too hard because
everybody sort of gravitated toward them
but they I remember the person said the
ones who really wanted it so badly were
the ones that it was always kind of out
of their reach I thought
might be true in some sense
yeah no I mean I can relate to that I
think once you get good at something and
the struggle doesn't come as often
it's it can be not as exciting I don't
know I think I think it's addictive
almost to have this puzzle you're always
working on whether it's artistic or
career or business-wise you know and I
think I mean even after making uh my
debut feature I feel like okay cool I've
done a Coming of Age Indie drama like
never have to do that again
but it meanwhile I I do I that's not
true at all really but I think that's
where the struggling artists that may
never be apart from me at this point uh
comes in and it's like you you have to
struggle more you have to you have to
continue to challenge yourself uh which
I think can be healthy but I think it's
important for for any artist to to
Outsource their opinions with their
friends and and really take a good look
at what their strengths are so they can
build on that
um and uh make great things but then
again I would love to like go away for
two years and like become a sick guitar
player you know what I mean like you
know like because it's hard it's so hard
you know
um uh so yeah there's definitely a
balance of
um I guess continuing your natural
talent and also challenging yourself
you know and making money somewhere in
there
yeah where would you go
would you go to Peru would you go to oh
man Fiji
if I could just escape and go somewhere
play guitar for two years yeah
specifically with guitar
it's nowhere cold because I can't I I
live on a farm now I'm I'm playing
guitar outside this morning it was
freezing I'm like you know I'm
regressing on my guitar because it's so
cold you can't use your fingers uh I
don't know I went to Mexico City for a
while and that's where I write uh wrote
part of a new script I'm working on I
like I like that place a lot in the
summertime that's where I would go
Mexico City again okay and you can
always have the fingerless gloves right
yeah yeah there you go that would really
make it Seattle the fingerless gloves